live from South by Southwest 2013 power
98.3 bootleg Capcom sitting here with
the homie man represent ATL funk volume
bent a bit what's up man yo man hey man
them shoes as flies [__] yo man imma
[__] adidas kind of sewer man so I
appreciate that [__] I appreciate I
appreciate people who [__] with shoes
that aren't Jordans yeah - man adidas is
the first [__] hip-hop sneaker that's
real [__] cuz don't know that adidas was
the free stripes all day took hip hop on
Run DMC boom I appreciate everybody's on
Jordans dick man yo Jordan [__] Jordans
that's my [__] mantra adidas yeah
plugs no we need may we make it - [__]
James
we will not be slaves - Jordan and his
13 new sneaker releases a year [__] that
or a month skies all day they don't need
to hire me man on his [__] new
campaign eventually they were a man I
see you got that onyx t on though man
[__] be sleeping man back the [__] up
and uh what's my what's the album with
oh my god is down DZ him down - have a
nice day
hey let me ask you man coming from
Atlanta you have an onyx t-shirt on your
music your flow is very I mean you're a
very lyrical dude man oh yeah and I know
a lot of people try to [__] on Atlanta
like you know like I know there's a lot
of a lot of now I want to say basic ass
rappers in Atlanta rappers who who don't
really depend on their lyrics - yeah but
then you got guys like goody mob
yourself were some of your heavier
influences cuz you know [__] man
I feel like you kind of you got some
crate like you you a funny ass do man
you and your lyrics is kind of crazy bro
I got some I got some out awkward
[__] influences man I grew up growing
up in the a like when I came up like the
[__] that was poppin was like
their booty shaking [__] right some of
this [__] was cool but I didn't [__]
with it right a lot of I was so man I
was in the like wu-tang heaven that's
tight wu-tang [__] a [__] company
flow flow flow that's crazy you know who
else man I can't when Outkast came out
man that's when I was like these
[__] crazy Outkast em oh so you
[__] with that that real [__] is the
[__] that [__] uh create a jam be
dope
I can hear that [__] in the end - man
that's what's up the freebase of the
only prize I got heard from you I don't
know if you have any other tapes out but
the freebase with Kevin Bacon should I
heard yeah I got two more I'm working
I'm about to put another one out
probably like two months
that shit's hard one that won't work you
know what's crazy is I never heard of
you before and I was just scrolling on
like to go boys and that artwork yeah it
was like yo shout out there's parens on
them and I saw the title really freebase
with Kevin Bacon you really did I really
did man I was a Hollywood I saw man you
know this story I'm [__] and my real
[__] yeah we really mean Kevin Bacon we
smoked some of that uh [__] some rock
cocaine and that's where the album came
from that's good I just I had a project
before that called huffing glue a
Hasselhoff
oh [__] huh flew off and I was like yo I
said you know what I want to continue
that [__] I like that [__] so I want it
what's the next one you know what the
new project I'm working on now is more a
little bit more serious okay trying to
get people to know who the [__] I am a
little bit so I'm I still got some crazy
[__] on there but it's a little bit more
retrospective [__] so people can
understand you know a little bit more
know a little bit know a little more
about you because I feel like that's
important you gotta let people in your
life a little bit I think a lot of other
projects they just it's just kind of wow
so this one it's still wild but a little
tame and and I'm going back to the crazy
[__]
grab a little bit of crazy [__] though
on ah
[__] it's so [__] crazy sorry the
rugged man yeah it's [__] dope who
did I just see RA did a record with
I think tec-9 he just put a joint out
with tec-9 I [__] with re the rugged man
his joint on sound Baumann was my [__]
oh he sound Baumann - yeah he's dope
yeah for sure okay so uh we got a
project coming out you have the title
my grandma's basement that's the [__]
title man
my grandma's basement of crazy [__]
started it and how's this funk volume
right bin bro seems like man you your
[__] going over the world yeah you
probably having a sex with a lot of
strange girls you should be let me ask
you a question
I feel like ICP groupies like realtalk
are probably like the worst kind of
group is to have right to be fair it's a
bunch of tore down white girls for the
most part I meant to that though you're
in the tour gown torn oh [__] how would
the funk volume girls that love funk
volume about the same tore down white
girls girls hey I had one chick she
wanted me to pour beer on her head so on
her head yeah I'm like why you was
having sex
oh no no literally I [__] PBR - is
crazy loved it - it is crash and I saw
all of my white trash sisters and it's
awesome alright do I'm looking forward
to the new project South by Southwest
you are out here Amalia man anybody who
you you're collaborating on this on with
this new project that like I said you
kind of you know you got some out there
lyrics man I can see besides already the
rugged man were you [__] with on this
project it's a couple of people I'm
trying to I it is nothing set in stone
I'm just to reach out this who are you
trying to reach out to trying to reach
out to [__] Danny Brown in Action
Bronson oh I need them two [__] on
some [__] that'd be crazy it would be
crazy hey I'm here probably they running
around see him yeah make that [__] had a
deselect actually got a he sent me some
tracks man so it's my guy [__] shout out
the static select the mouth [__] with
him heavy the physiology [__] he did
with harmonized oh yo and a little
famous for yeah all that 1982 she
Jarren Benton in this [__] I'm fine now
that I know how much of a thorough ass
hip-hop head Jaron is no yo no [__] can
it no Nick in the [__] history I
gonna say that I'm gonna [__] myself up
but no one can beat me in a hip-hop
history contest nobody nobody ok let me
ask you this now we're not talking about
that's rapid time who's the best
lyricist of all time in your eyes
lyricist I can I don't know man it's
every is so many dope lyricist and they
all got so many different elements yeah
I gotta say em you know what- slept on
wrasse Andre throw the threat oh yeah
this guy knows me [__] [__] who else man
is so many man's ok well let's go one
more on some hip-hop [__] who do you
think has the most underrated album of
all time it's the most underrated album
ever I say the most underrated artists
who don't get the respect that I think
they deserve is probably red man that's
some real [__] and I don't know why he
started a lot of [__] - Sean price -
chump
yo damn dude that's who I was thinking
of Sean price is wanted yo let me say
this [__] - real quick when I [__]
have writer's block and I can't think of
some [__] I swear to God no [__] out
those be Sean price on and like
literally like yup that [__] is
the beach he's one of the big [__] yo
when it comes to rapping not like he's
one of them to this day yo price is that
guy help to scout the [__] man all day
all day and you know what this they put
out the third album was the most left on
[__] album yeah man that's a crazy
ass project or I do well I'm definitely
[__] with you a lot more now than I
was about time saying I [__] with the no
I just like to you know watch sports I
mean I can't keep up with it man being
in the [__] horn
porn star man now watch what a problem
of porn I'm in mature porn much the
older white ladies I was lying
like nina hartley no boys I don't even
know their names would be a lot of [__]
that's like from [__] Sweden and god
you're so you watch that like an issue
with porn like I prefer like I just I I
see the only thing I don't do is white
girls it's my guy I don't [__] white
girls that's my thing Gianna [__]
Michaels gianna michaels with the red
hair now she got black hair she she's
beast yes
didn't you have red hair she's got
really big titties and her neck her
nipples blend into her Ted and her dawn
game is vicious yeah I know Michaels
yeah yeah that's who I'm trying to
[__] get it if I was single you're
not single I'm not oh so that so that's
why you're in a porn so much because
anybody was in a relationship jerks off
a lot
he hit it on the [__] nail he hit it
on a nail if you're in a relationship
like I am and you've been in there for a
long time you knuckle enough you you
knuckle up knuckle enough bare minimum
five times a week
shoutout to xtube and spank wire and all
that [__] sad eggs videos xvideo is my
favorite because they post the whole 30
minutes yes and you got that you got the
option to see no you know I want it I
wanna make the head and then you always
got to try to like when you're about to
bus you try to cut like no homo scream
it out like you try to time it out with
the dude who's coming like on the girl
face right I've never done that
why should he put me on some new [__] oh
my man Jerad been basically Kevin Bacon
is available right now and my grandma's
basement coming soon font volume all
[__] day
funk volume in this [__] [__] at me if
I have a [__] interview today right
there